[Music]
well thank you so much anu
and we're gonna go e45 we're gonna play
classical style of chess
um and uh let's go knight c6
all right so let's play the four knights
defense this is one of the most common
openings at this level
and um by the way i will leave time at
the very end of the speed run for random
questions i will not make detours to
answer opening questions he plays the
four night scotch
so he opens up the center this is an
opening that i recommend to a lot of
beginners
because it opens up the center and it
and it basically gives diagonals for
both pieces so
taking a look at this bishop where can
you guys propose that we put this bishop
but not but to develop actively and to
develop a tempo
where can we put this bishop there's two
good moves there's two good moves c5 is
one
which we're going to play and b4 is the
other these are the two main moves
i play bishop c5 myself at a grand
master level
bishop b4 is the most popular move okay
he's gone bishop e3
now alert alert alert alert he wants to
take our knight
and when we take back he takes our
bishop our bishop is undefended
can we move this bishop onto a square
where it is defended
can we drop this bishop somewhere where
it is defended yeah there should be six
that's the main move this is the main
line
actually queen f3
alerts a little bit what has he done
what has he done
what has he done
he has confused something he has hung
his knight two attackers one defender
boom
that's it i'll explain um i'll explain
the subtleties of the move
bishop e6 after the game okay so he
actually is helping us by training
um i'm writing all this down okay so
he's gone queen g3 now we already know
how to respond in such situations we do
not get intimidated by a single queen
how do we how do we proceed no reason to
take the knife
we castle beautiful guys there's no
reason to take the night yet
if he castles okay now he's attacking
our bishop
now it makes sense to take the knight
and not only does it make sense to trade
here but it makes sense to do what in
this position
this comes back to the principle that we
do not take pieces at random but if
there is a pawn or a piece that's just
hanging there and we don't damage our
position by taking it
we take it now it's going to be very
important here guys
to develop the rest of our queen side we
don't want to spend forever with these
pieces and we actually have a really
high level move here
it's a move that might be a little bit
difficult for some of you guys to
understand
dornev got it now we can drop the knight
back and then play d6 but can we kill
two birds with one son amazing
i'm actually very impressed we can play
the move d5
now this move has two purposes the first
is to protect the knight
the second is to open up a path for the
bishop now you guys might say but daniel
wait a sec can he take the pawn
well that leads to a trait of queens and
a pawn is a very small price to pay
to trade queens particularly since f2
would be hanging at the end of the line
and i'll show that later
okay what do we do now we cannot take
because the queen is defending what's a
good move here guys
bishop f5 very good morrigan
is on fire getting the bishop out and
protecting the knight now he could play
f3
and chase the knight away and then we
would have to be very careful he goes
queen g5
um so let's uh let's defend this bishop
shall we
let's let's uh make this bishop secure
how can we do that
no need for queen g5 check let's just go
bishop g6 now if he takes on e4 what
are we going to take back with if we
take on okay
he's got here and this is a great
opportunity for us to trade some pieces
there is a great opportunity for us to
trade some pieces here
particularly since he's got very active
pieces okay so when your opponent has
active pieces like this
no need to go pawn hunting no need to go
pawn hunting let's trade queens
how do we trade queens i want to trade
queens though i want to show you guys
how to win when you decide to trade
pieces czechovich
chaka ruski's we trade queens we take it
but daniel you're blundering upon again
it doesn't matter because we're up a
piece but he doesn't even take it he
goes bishop e5
how do we protect the spawn in the best
possible way
how do we protect the spawn in the best
possible way c6 is beautiful
and then we need to find a way to
continue now in such situations
okay well thank you very much for the
bishop see think he's mikhail tal or
something what do we do
all we need to do now is just bring our
pieces in and trade pieces
we've decided to trade pieces so let's
continue with that particular strategy
how do we bring pieces in and trade
pieces at the same time
rook f to e8 offering a rook trade
thank you very much and
now we have what's called an open file
but before we do anything ladies and
gentlemen i want to take care of my
future self
i don't want any problems
with my back rank so why don't we take a
second
and create a hole for the king i know
that rookie 2 would be better but i want
to show you guys how to play with an
abundance of caution
now we can penetrate the second rank
okay
always do this now let's start taking
pawns i'm going to play a little bit
faster here
because uh we have a minute now here's
the thing
how are we going to actually win this
position a lot of people
would continue to take odds but we are
already up to pieces guys we don't need
to
keep taking pods how you win such
positions is by identifying a passed
upon
and pushing it to promotion what is the
past pawn that we want to push here
what is the most far advanced and in
fact the only pass bond we have
but we need to get the shortcut of the
way first we don't play c5 because we
dropped the pawn how do we get the rook
out
get this goddamn rook out of d4 96 is
perfect
we don't worry guys remember i i am
pretty good at bullets so
oh isn't it isn't it great that we
played h6 how did i know that we'd one
day need this well
fantastic that's exactly why you play
these moves
okay let's push i don't care what he
does our king is so safe here it's as
safe as can be
guess what the knight okay i'm just
closing my eyes and pushing the pawn he
cannot stop the pawn
even if he could we would do this but we
just take and uh that's it
that's it queen and uh
we have checkmate in two moves could
somebody please find
the checkmate in two could somebody
please find the checkmate in two
that is correct and that is correct
okay all right guys let's analyze
now this is the scotch
so this is the four night scotch now a
lot of people would say
and i'll take everyone's questions
please be patient a lot of people say
wait a second
you said that it was a bad idea to bring
queens out in the opening
and generally it is but there is one key
exception when there is no knight on b8
and you can you can rotate this however
you want this queen is a lot better than
usual
because there is no knight c6 possible
what about c5 doesn't this attack the
queen well it does
but what is the drawback of the move c5
this smooth c5 is a horrible positional
move and yet a lot of people play it
because the queen can even come back to
d1 that's not the best move
but i want you guys to tell me what this
does to black's position
look at this juice right here look at
this beautiful juicy square
that has been now created because the
pawn cannot go back to c6
in addition it weakens the d-pawn it
weakens the c pawn and
there's one more thing i want you guys
to identify about the move c5
in terms of black's development what
does it actually make more difficult
what does it make more it blocks the
bishop now the bishop has to go to a
very passive square
because the pawn is obstructing our own
development
okay this is exactly what we practiced
for that is the reason why we develop
our bishop bishop b4
is more popular that is also perfectly
legitimate and now the main line goes
take stakes bishop d3 this is a
theoretical line i won't delve into it i
had this in one of my games
i played bishop c5 and here it's very
very important to always identify the
hanging pieces
bishop on c5 is undefended um
now somebody could say wait a second
daniel you talked about intermediate
moves
why can't we first take the bishop and
only after he takes back
take the knight well we could except
this is a botez gambit
this is a botez gambit we have to watch
our queen at all times
and uh so for that reason we protect our
queen now the main line here is queen d2
i've had this again these are these are
lines that i have in my own games
um it's not like i'm playing special
openings
to condescend to you guys i practice
what i preach i've had plenty of games
that went exactly in this way in fact
right off the top of my head i can
remember one game i played recently
uh which continued uh precisely in this
manner
in a protested game watch this see the
gm's do this gms do this stuff too um
and this is the main line this game
ended in a draw
um and so this is the main line white
castle's short and black
white sorry black castle shore black
white castles long and we essentially
get a situation where we have attacks on
opposite sides of the board
that is a situation we have not talked
about it yet it's advanced
but you guys can understand that
generally here black attacks on
the queen side and white attacks on the
king side
and these are some of the most
exhilarating lines and positions
in chess because we have two attacks and
either side is trying to make the other
okay but back to reality
mom spaghetti back to reality um
queen f3 was the move that he played
confusing with some other blinds and he
hangs the knight
and the rest is very simple we castle
takes
knight blue cole thank you so much for
the subway switch i appreciate the
support guys
and um he goes queen d4 now this is the
move that i think some of you guys might
have found a little bit puzzling
uh which is the move d5 um and um
why do we play d5 again i hope people
understand jax
thank you for the five months that if he
trades queens
not only can we recapture on f2 but even
if we wouldn't be able to this would be
very much
worthwhile we only give up a pawn and in
return we're able to trade queens
okay um what else do i have to say about
this
we could have dropped the knight back
and gone d6 but this would have been a
little bit slower
could somebody explain to me why the
move queen takes e4 would not win a
piece because it's because of the pin
and this is actually something that you
would have to pay very very careful
attention to
yeah we're almost to let's get this to
2000 boys this is close
uh but i appreciate all the support it's
not quinchify check
because the one thing that i haven't
pointed out to you guys about the
desperado situation
is a danger of giving a check like this
because now i could remove my queen and
defend against the check at the same
time
i could remove my queen and defend
against check at the same time in fact i
could counter the check
and count her attacker queen this gets
very complicated but it's just very
simple
because there's no more checks and we
get our queen out or we trade queens
all we have to do guys is take the queen
because at the end if we count up the
material we have two rooks in white as
one we are up a rook
yes we're not up a queen but we're up a
rook in the end game so for that reason
queen takes e4 would not have been
possible but if our rook wasn't on f8
we would have to be very attentive to
things like that
whenever there is an extra here's the
principle to remember
whenever there is an x-ray between a
rook and a queen
what is an x-ray a situation where
there's a rook on one side of the board
and an opposing queen on the other
and there's a bunch of pieces that are
in the way
you have to pay attention to that x-ray
because x-ray tactics are among the most
easily and most often missed
tactics on the chessboard because you
don't think that it's significant
but this x-ray is super super important
we want to be very careful about it
okay what about f5 instead of d5 well f5
would not have accomplished the task
of also preparing to develop the bishop
so it also would have weakened the king
so this would have been fine but not
great okay so we developed the bishop
if he would have gone f3 could somebody
remind me where we need to move this
knight
where do we need to move this knight in
order not to give up the bishop
we could also by the way give a check on
g5 first and move it to f6 but no we
need to do that knight d6 defends the
bishop and we are fine
remember guys there are two ways of
broadly speaking of winning a position
when you are up
a lot of material that means a piece or
more option one
is to use that extra piece and try to
attack your opponent
because by definition if you have 11 men
on the soccer field
and your opponent has 10 it's easier to
score a goal
the other option is to start trading and
to trade queens to trade pieces because
at the end of the day if you have only
one piece and your opponent has zero
that's also very easy to win remember
that i went into the intricacies of
when one option is better than the other
why am i choosing to trade
and not try to attack in this position
why am i choosing scenario two here
could somebody explain to me
conceptually
conceptually why am i choosing the
other option here
trade your pieces before you blunder
them exactly
bingo because both things are protected
and also white is very active look at
white's pieces
they are all mobilized boom boom boom
boom
i don't want to mess with that okay if i
am careless why it's actually going to
cause some damage here
so for that reason my training pieces
i'm disarming white's position
i'm making his pieces less active and in
general
uh just i you know this is just going to
be very easy and also because i have
open files and i can use these open
files
to trade a bunch of pieces including the
rooks that is sort of the
uh the background explanation for why i
chose
to trade queens in this situation um
knight takes f2 would have been possible
but pretty complicated
simplify the position and the rest is
very simple h6
everybody makes everybody understands
and here
one of the you could take on g2 and take
everything but the fundamental way of
winning such a position
step one identify pass pawn
a pass spawn is a pawn that has no pawns
obstructing it
now the crucial thing to remember here
guys
a little bit of a course in the end game
let's say we have the following position
is the h-bond passed
is the h-bond passed yes or no
more again i could have done either it
really doesn't matter yes
because it can go all the way to
promotion the e-pawn is obviously not
passed
what if we were to remove the h
now the h1 is not passed
is the e bond passed is the epon pass
now
is it passed nope very good you're not
falling for it because the f pawn is not
on the same file but it is stopping the
e bond from progressing but
if we were to move this panel as well
then the e-pawn is passed
because it can move all the way to
promotion okay
that is the philosophy behind past fonts
it's important to just
to have that distinction in mind
um okay so for that reason we identified
the pass pawn and then we identified the
obstruction to the past but in this case
it's the rook
this piece is called the blockader this
is the blockading piece so we remove
technically the blockading piece
and we do not play c5 because that
blunders the pawn
and we just push that's all i'm doing is
pushing the pawn and then we deliver the
checkmate
very very simple very straightforward no
rocket science
obviously there is a lot more to it
there's different ways of winning
positions like that
but this is the most classically minded
you just identify the pass bond
and then you just eliminate the
obstructions or you create pass bonds
okay if you don't have a pass bond you
can create one either by just taking a
bunch of your opponent's pawns
or by using your own pawns to
orchestrate a breakthrough
for example here if you wanted to create
a pass pawn if for example the d-pawn
was not passed
you could just like take a bunch of puns
and now the fbi would be passed that's
also
perfectly fine appreciate that dave
hammett and let's play
one more game any other questions yeah
we did have a nice mate that was made in
three we also had rook takes a two
eliminating the pawn and then mating him
on the a file that was also possible why
did we play bishop survivor bishop
before if we go bishop b6 after bishop
e3
we're just moving the same piece twice
fantastic question
yes we're moving the same piece twice
but this is a bit of an exception to the
rule because
it's okay to move one piece twice we're
not moving all of the pieces twice
and also this creates tension a standoff
between the two bishops aquila pointed
out a great point
if white takes both pieces what piece do
we take back with and what do we gain by
taking
that piece
we take not with the c pawn we take
toward the center and look at this
we open up the rook so by doing nothing
except recapturing we have opened up the
rook and given this rook
prospect while it stands on its initial
square
okay so that's another perk of going
bishop b6
we have this kind of standoff and black
benefits from the standoff if white
releases the tension first
that is not white's best move white's
best move is queen to 200 bits thank you
so much
okay last two questions i have seen
queen's gambit
and i've talked about it yesterday i
know we'll talk about it again can you
show how
you would use the open a file i don't
know how to actually use the
app so you could use it if white castles
block
if we have a scenario like this okay
take a look at this can we take on a2
obviously no we cannot but can somebody
propose a plan
for getting this knight out of c3 and
then guess what once we take on a2 it'll
be devastating
knight takes c4 is the tactical method
we could sacrifice the knight
and get the rook to a2 that would be
very interesting because we're
threatening checkmate
but the non-sacrificial way would be
just to push the b-pawn to b4
get the knight out of the picture and
take on a2 and that's how attacking
plans begin that is why open files or
semi-open files which this is this is a
semi-open file
which is which means that there is an
opponent's pawn on that file or a piece
or sorry just upon but we get the
defending pieces
out of the way is there a consistent way
to create past funds with pawn trades
yeah there's pawn breakthroughs and i'll
get into that later
last question why wouldn't you take with
a c pawn over the a pawn
is the benefit of opening the file
greater but i would argue
dolphin that there is no benefit to
taking with a c pawn
there there is just i mean i don't
understand entirely why you would even
take with a c pawn right i guess you
correct your pawn structure
but you also create a very big weak
square here
okay normally you take toward the center
that is one of the key rules toward
recapturing
that rule has a lot of exceptions i
could show you plenty of examples
of taking away from the center in fact
there are situations
that i could show you where a very
strong player
decides to ruin his pawn structure in
order to do something such as open a
file
so sometimes it is so important to open
a file
that you would actually you would
actually
ruin your pawn structure
that is a worthy price to pay for
opening a file for one of your rooks
and one of my favorite examples of that
let me show you one moment please
is the game between
okay no not here uh just please bear
with me for a hot second guys
i'm trying to find this one particular
game
i think mama yara was the one who did
this
so i think definitely mom and dara was
involved
um yeah
tiara was involved i think
and he played i think maybe it was a
rhonian mummy drop
it was a game in the goes in ah come on
come on find the position
just give me one more second guys please
please thank you
pretty please
it's a rogozin i remember that was a
rugosin
and this is a really nice example it is
worth the wait i promise
it was worth the wait if i don't find it
with this search then i won't
include it at all but i'll find it later
all right now that was a different game
i was i swear there was carlson against
mamidyarov
but i don't remember um
for some reason i can't remember exactly
how this was
done
um it was a rhonian pram nick maybe
it was a rhonian kramnik corolla
neritsky that was another game
um and if not i will just play the next
game guys i know i know i'm taking a
while here
aronian no aronia kramnik no
okay guys i'll find it later the bottom
line is that white took on g3 with a
pawn
rather than taking on h3 i will find
that game guys
if somebody knows what i'm talking about
maybe you can tell me who was playing
for some reason i can't can't find the
exact uh
games i don't remember who was playing i
will find it i promise that this game
exists
but for the time being since i have only
10 minutes left let's play one more game
off the instructive speedrun you guys
ready for this
you guys ready for this um it was
carlson mamidyarov i can swear
um or maybe carlson aronian
the carlson against cerrone maybe mommy
dyarv is simply in my imagination last
search
last search might have been carlson
against aronian
and then we will do some speedrunning
i found it yes amazing i'm really pumped
right now
i really pumped okay i found it
100 subs charge for seeing this game
okay so the bottom line is
in this position this is what's called
the rogozin variation
and after knight takes g3 magnus made a
crazy move that was a novelty
this position had occurred a million
times and white always took h takes g3
okay instead magnus carlsen plays the
crazy
f takes g3 weakening his pawn
opening his king and he does all of this
in order to open that f-file because he
thinks that one day
he's gonna put a rook on f1 by castling
and he's going to attack that pawn
which is exactly well
it doesn't end up happening it doesn't
end up happening because aronian
sensing that castles the other way but
by and large if mag
if aronian had basically gone well
carlson could have castled and basically
he could have gotten the apple
long story short it was a crazy move at
the time
how why would you do that but he won the
game so you can see at the grand master
level this kind of stuff occurs
sometimes you want to ruin your pawn
structure and open a file
okay let's continue the speed run
[Music]
you